welcome to this video playing Alex it is
one of those guys who always place them
the London system so I want to do
something to prevent the London I'm not
in the mood for that opening yeah come
on let's do something some crazy-looking
stuff
yeah it's pretty hard to inject life
until into this kind of stuff yeah just
92
it's not not much happening
there's some way to to get some fun into
this okay let's say let's try try that
yeah probably you will play just H for
no he doesn't
yeah just teasing am a pity on the
diagonal
yeah this is probably not too great yeah
but they're it i want i want some some
interesting interesting game and not
this one hundred move shuffling of the
london when you can you can play the
london system with some ambition but
usually just shuffles i was just
preparing to get a square on on the only
five
94 yeah I don't know it's it's it's
quite a strange position I have no idea
what's going on ready both sides seem to
have their problems
and this is really funny can also play
this first
and even be too
should I wish I play b2 and exchange in
this in this manner okay why not it is
just a blitz game so rook rook take it
takes a look at take it rook if we move
that I just I just put my look on a try
for something H 505 a 2 this is
full-scale CinemaScope just look aged 55
e 2 if he just needs to take h 8 i'm not
quite sure what he's thinking about okay
the question is can I trap this this is
strange night this is Magnus maybe good
attacking c3 enter taking you for yeah
this sir but it's it's mostly a check
not more
check Kim yet I don't really see a big
point
take it take it mmm should be 325 i
don't i don't get it i take everything
I'm just a greedy person
like three extra points now
yeah at least i got some fun into this
game it's not like the the london
shuffle all the time and front factors
that i can actually even castle long
here would be funny to get this in the
real later stage of the game okay i like
to have the Queen's off this is this is
helpful getting into the end game with
three extra points
white resigns yeah yeah probably it was
it was far too far too creative but okay
didn't really I look like him refuted it
but the wrong TM this should be I should
be better for white be free i think it's
a it's a bit shaky i don't know this
looks good now i get i get b 3 and i
take it take p 3 i'll get this get this
night on c4 ok this was funny ya i ti
Bishop takes a son because I did that ok
I hear if I found 'if I've was
interesting here I intended just to go
night before but I'm not sure now that
it's really working but this I can just
take kami yeah this is just just pawns
for nothing and of course this is ok the
easiest just get get rid of everything I
should have casted long here if I had
the chance I could I could get along
here on move 31 forgot about it
unfortunately alright thanks for
watching